comment allez-vous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle année je me prononce pas à tout
moment elle est pire que celle d' avance
écoutez la vidéo d'aujourd'hui c'est
juste histoire de bien commencer l'année
de vous mettre en confiance pour cette
année que vous soyez épanouie ce jour 1
écoutez lucioles m'a concocté un google
docs de la honte
ça fait peur dans google docs a que des
vieux trucs deux mois contre est née sur
le net donc ça peut être des postes
facebook installent twitter on avait
déjà fait ne fera pas aujourd'hui à
certains postes qui fait de mon facebook
et les qui datent de ya 10 11 ans quand
j'avais 13 ans et sa maman comme on
grandit et comme on oublie qui on était
à cette époque là et comment s'exprimer
à cette époque là écoutez moi alors elle
m'a dit que ces gens là gigant que
j'étais vraiment un bébé jeter un pv k2
bref comment on va un peu rigoler par
contre être palais ou sinon je déterre
aussi beau vieux pas sur vos réseaux
faire cette palais ouvre ses parties
photo postée par nat ou de février 2015
ça va ce pas c'est mignon ça attendez
c'était on voit clairement qu'ils
avaient un thème au contraire c'est
plutôt style et j'ai respecté le thème
j'ai respecté la fait pas chier photo
postée par cyprien d'avril 2014 mais
lauren je peux dormir en voiture vous
attend on n'est pas du tout d'accord sur
les trucs beauté ou pas honteux pour moi
hier 2 août est d'ailleurs ça depuis que
les masques du coup bas tout le monde en
a recommencé génial pour moi je peux
dormir dans les transports la bouche
grande ouverte personnes le voit quel
plaisir ici présent toujours rien de
honteux pour moi le honteux aux maîtres
ne s'excitent pas du tout la photo de
couverture de 2012 je chiale hockey la
hoya et s'accumulent plus tard si vous
saviez comme j'étais fier de ce montage
si vous saviez
regardez ce détour âge il est impeccable
et je vous jure que ça pour du 2012
c'était incroyable j'vous jure
le chapeau était sûrement de trop oui le
chapeau est effectivement de trop pour
qui tu te prends lithium
[ __ ] hébreu mais moi qui dort en moi
les gars je suis sur un combo la sais
pas je déteste ces gens qui font ça
écoutez moi bien vous en avez plein
autour de vous écouter les gens qui
tente un truc vestimentaire et qui du
coup dans la décision de la photo mais
thomas ça c'est un jeu cette allée trop
loin dans l'espoir que des gens viennent
leur dire mais non ça te va bien mon
bichon mais non pourquoi tu dis ça ça ne
va pas ça pue la merde
d'accord tout couvre-chef toi jamais dû
mettre au chaud extrême mais ça m'énerve
et je le fais tellement ça c'est pour ça
que ça m'énerve autant je les fais ya
pas longtemps mais voilà ça j'adore les
couvre-chefs surtout ceux dioko mais
aucun ne va avec ma tête
on dirait je sors de prison à ce bain
demain réveil 7h40 courage tu dis
courage à toute l'humanité
à tulle ac était propre statut ouais
mais c'était pas la honte à l'époque on
faisait tous ça
non attendez vous voulez dire que dix
ans après je me rends compte que non il
y avait que moi 31 décembre 2010 voir à
14 ans sans que ce soir ça va être une
pure soirée
geof mauvais mon pote va jouer à fifa un
mec
et si tout se passe bien je vais claqué
mon premier ce mac os ou je sais plus ce
que c'était mon nouvel an 2010
mais quatorze ans ça devait pas être je
vais être très honnête ça devait pas
être un truc de ouf
aussi je crois que c'était un truc de
ouf c'était une grosse soirée chez un
pote à wissous et là tout ce capitalisme
vous fait du bruit
la personne je veux stoppée mais
recherchent maintenant shell trop comme
lech l'été aux oligarques et consulat l
île au lit le voilà je crois qu est ce
que j'appelais les défis de ouf
c'étaient les petits paris entre potes
on faire défi de ouf n empêche
visionnaire c'est devenu un concept de
bellefeuille carlito huit heures plus
tard et le coche le 19 septembre 2010 a
eu chaud aux fesses
ah ouais ce jour là rast et chaud avec
ma mère à la fine grille est en train de
faire du pc en cachette acheter un os x
c'est pour ça que je faisais des défis
de ouf se fait chier un [ __ ] mais
c'est vrai que le 4 février 2010
souvenez vous c'était pas la grosse
ambiance
on se faisait pas mâché n'ya pas youtube
genre pouvait que jouer à des jeux et là
évidemment j'étais privé de pc
apparemment écoutez vous pouvez me juger
en ce moment même et rire et au soufre
et du net ou du mois je vous en veux pas
mais sachez que là je vais sur votre
facebook c'est sûr il ya des phrases
comme ça a marqué en mode passif pareil
c'est sur le 14 avril 2009
à ces thèmes et de jean et deux pick-up
et aura demain sa sacoche sacoche et le
starter pack du gangster mais attention
alors ceux qui me voient comme un petit
un petit gâteau là j'ai braqué une
boulangerie toujours après est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous étiez comme moi quand vous
vouliez 3 un truc vous by passiez vos
parents pour demander direct à votre
grand-mère et quelquefois avec de la
chance elle demandait pas aux parents si
elle pouvait acheter ça pour toi elle
lâcheté d'elle-même qui faisait ça qui
faisait ça tellement voilà bah tiens le
look final
elle est estimée franchement les gars tn
petit tee shirt s'est passé quoi il ya
de la couleur on aime bien
pantacourt tu as des chances de séduire
une fille c'est zéro banon aux impôts
attendez c'est incroyable je suis en
train de refaire cette coupe
je vous jure je en train de refaire
cette coupe mais il ya également ce qui
est arrivé entre temps
regardez alors écoutez je vais vous
donner les coulisses de cette photo
parce que je m'en souviens étonnamment
en fait je crois quand tu es petit tu
t'attaches beaucoup d'affection est
d'importance à certaines choses et tu
t'en souviens des années plus tard et
quand tu te souviens tu te dis mais
pourquoi je me souviens de ça c'était
une méga basique mais non l époque
c'était incroyable vous savez ce qui est
un droit pour moi à l'époque ceux où dix
mecs c'est un peu ou dit noir à rayures
blanches et pourtant le seul bon à
chaque fois que je m'étais je me sentais
trop bien trop puissant et haut du coup
ça c'était ma photo de profil en 2010
c'est franchement je pense que de mon
groupe de potes
j'avais la meilleure de photos de profil
à celle là les plus anciens je sais que
j'ai déjà montrés dans une vidéo chez
plus laquelle on l'a déjà vu messieurs
dames
j'ai tenté la coupe super saiyan pas mal
ça stoppe franchement opus y avait
c'était la période un peu tectoniques et
tout ça allait bien avec ce qui
m'entourait honnêtement de grosse prise
de risques dans le choix des photos de
profil je vais dire lorraine rigole
c'est déjà dur 2 cm alors c'est mais en
photo à cet âge là c'est encore plus
difficile lorsque son corps évoluer
qu'on n'assume pas forcément ce qu'il
devient alors je vais dire ton petit
mépris l'a battu que le feu au cul
monroe mais quel séducteur attendait si
tu aperçois ce mec sur une plage tu
t'assois à côté de lui il ya eu une
époque comme ça sur facebook où tout le
monde mettait de la saturation à mort
sur ces photos c'est comme s'ils à
l'image d'un coup elle devenait comme ça
la voilà bah là on est bien 2012 voyez
épreuve de ça la première vidéo de la
chaîne donc c'est sur crysis regarder la
couleur du gameplay pareil séméga saturé
je vous jure on aimait trop saturé les
trucs à l'époque et après on a saturé de
la saturation
je suis pas peu fier à l'époque avait
pas masquer logiciel pour retoucher les
photos en plus c'était sur pc il n'y
avait pas y est passé sur téléphone et
avait la team des pros
qui avait craqué photoshop et la team
des pauvres comme moi qui avaient
téléchargé photofiltre un tout petit
monde mais qui change tellement de
choses c'est là que les révisions pour
le bac commerce n empêche qui parmi vous
avait mis en place une telle
méthodologie pour le bac tout le monde
très bien à l'époque je m'étais taper du
giga des terres pour avoir mon bac donc
trois mois avant parce que je savais que
si je n'obtenais je pouvais prendre une
année foule youtube du coup j'ai tous
classés comme ça par couleur selon les
matières bla bla bla et en fait j'ai
acheté le salon pas comme tous les camps
l'ajout jeunes dans les pochettes il
manque les deux tiers des courants vers
la team caso c'est ce qu'on révise est
que via des annabac et pas autre chose
c'est nous représente on a la team cas
soc 13 buts bac es sannois ça c'est la
vie une salade hier sous pique ça c'est
la vie voyez je vous demande pas quand
je vous dis que j'ai toujours mangé
nullement et j'ai toujours pas pris le
temps de manger d'ailleurs regardez où
est posée la salade hier devant un
clavier d'ordi je peux marcher devant
l'ordi tout le temps j'en ai mangé
tellement de ces [ __ ] de salles à
dire la niçoise la parisienne lâchez pas
toi c'était ça ou un kebab il n'y avait
aucun entre deux eaux mais attendez ce
mec est sûre tender ou pas parce que si
oui je le match voici en exclu galaxie
aérienne la première et dernière
phototype kikoolol que je fais de ma vie
assure une fois dans ta vie tu voulais
faire un selphy devant ton miroir comme
tout le monde
félin ne te dois de peur voilà parfait
le kéké kikoolol typique à schnyder
génie hashtag lunettes hashtags a été
pris une minute après la photo d'avant
ouais d'accord c'est le début
d'installer filtrer et changer la donne
mais vous voyez beaucoup de saturation
toujours là des fois il y en a qui me
l'envoie sur twitter celle là en pensant
que c'est une faute au premier degré au
premier degré et imagine seller je vais
vous dire un truc bon d'un spi sur les
postes 1 stade n'a pas bougé d'un poil
c'est terrible je suis pas très actif
sur les réseaux sociaux et franchement
les postes des fois je me force à en
faire parce qu'il faut en faire et je
serai totalement capable d'en faire un
comme ça le même hall à
bouclier chaise alors nous sommes
fatigués je suis pas quoi dire là que je
vous dise 2013 une grande année pour
l'histoire de mon instagram une très
très grande année apparemment ça a l'air
bon le principe d'un kebab je suis pas
dire mieux attendait les coulisses de
cette photo sont très tristes le kebab
le plus proche de chez moi il n'était
pas à mes gars proches
et comme il faisait froid dehors le 30
mars ba le temps que je rentre chez moi
le kebab étaient froids et les frites
étaient molles on parle que des trucs
évident dans cette vidéo d'accord mais
ça nous fait plaisir donc je devais le
mettre un petit coup au four pour qu'ils
retrouvent finalement toute sa splendeur
et je trouve que c'est très triste
d'aller acheter un truc de fast food et
de devoir le mettre au four derrière
c'est super triste aujourd'hui je
préfère manger le truc froid que de le
mettre au four ont vraiment rachid
fierté c'est quoi ça à l'interface h et
un coup de vieux tew d'été c'est quoi on
mange je suis là dans 20 minutes désolé
maman je t'apprendrai ce que ça veut
dire non je suis désolé si tu regarde
cette vidéo je te rappelle qu'il ya
quand même une chanson qui parle de nous
voilà y'a pas que des dans ton cul
calais dans des combats ce qu'elle fit
scinder tu sais que tu dois aller te
coucher coach landais là on dirait une
autre dimension les mêmes ils sont tout
à rater yadir de malédiction il y en a
aucun qui est drôle quand tu es jeune tu
te fais une conclusion sur un truc genre
oh [ __ ] quand je suis fatigué je me
tiens tout le temps comme ça et tu as
vraiment envie de parler de cette
conclusion et de l'exposer au monde
genre comme si tu étais le premier à
atteindre fait cette remarque dans ça
vraiment marrant comme phénomène et tous
les jeunes passent par là c'est vraiment
rigolo
oh non mais tu vas arrêter de tees et et
douches la [ __ ] j'y aurais chemin des
douches il y avait une bande-annonce
quoi
[Musique]
terrible à ont fini sur de l'émotion hu
a sacré reward de youtube
le truc est limite plus grand que moi
c'est grâce à vous tous merci beaucoup
êtes top vous le méritez auriez plus que
moi sortez les bourgeois alors sachez
que j'ai encore cet objet celui qu'il ya
dans la photo au bureau et qu'il est
accroché au mur au dessus du bureau le
rêve d'ailleurs ça c'est l'ancien
trophée youtube d'un million il y en a
aussi un projet 100 milles et les deux
ils ont été changés bah non c'est juste
une plaque c'est plus un cadre avec un
bouton dedans à mes anciens étaient
mieux c'était mieux avant on rêverait je
peux le dire messieurs dames c'est la
fin de ce google docs de la honte
je vous avoue ça s'est bien mieux passé
que ce que je pensais en vrai c'était
plutôt cool je redoutais un peu puisque
vous savez je l'aï déjà dit mais moi
j'ai horreur de retomber sur des trucs
du passé je suis pas très à l'aise avec
le passé j'ai beaucoup de tendance à le
renier à être chez page pas bien mais là
franchement dans ces conditions c'était
plutôt agréable quoi qu'il en soit ne
supprimez pas les postes pas vieux mais
paraissant non plus que vous avez de
vous c'est la phase où on est le plus
tenté d'effacer toute trace d'une
période de notre vie cros n'assume pas
mais vraiment vous serez trop content de
tomber sur lui et pour les youtube la
faire une vidéo dessus c'est incroyable
en vrai c'est intéressant je découvre
qu'à l'époque j'utilisais vraiment les
réseaux sociaux de manière un peu intime
beaucoup plus personnel et tout est
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment les comptes
squeeze content que je mets juste de la
merde de suez mais constat de la vie de
tous les jours je les garde dans ma tête
et j'ai pas besoin d'extérioriser où que
ce soit bref j'espère que ça ne portera
chance pour l'un et 2021 tous ces petits
postes béante je vous dis à très vite et
faites gaffe à vos vieux passé tout
parce que là ça va les déballeurs là
croyez-moi là tout le monde va scanner
les vieux poste du tout bon et je fais
ce genre de remettre le cap comme si
j'allais rester sur l'ordi
[Musique]